The content of this MOOC is based on the
fantastic book
by Graham Hutton: Programming in Haskell.
I strongly recommend that,
as you follow the lectures,
you
read the chapters in the book for extra
background information
and deeper knowledge. Cambridge
University Press has been so kind
to offer you a 25% discount on
the book,
both on the printed version and on the
electronic version.
Of course, you don't have to type
in this URL here;
the URL will be available on the
course website,
Please consider to get the book
because I think it will
very much enhance the learning
experience of this MOOC.
Have a lot of fun and happy hacking!